it's hard to talk about this stuff
without sounding self-righteous that's
my nightmare i'm trying to not sound
self-righteous about all this because
it's my pet peeve when people are
self-righteous in conversations and i
try to remember though that when
someone's self-righteous it usually just
means they care so much about something
that they become an asshole right i do
it i'm guilty i am guilty i am very into
animal advocacy and oh thank you oh
that's very nice and i don't have kids
what else am i going to do
there are times when i am so passionate
about protecting an innocent animal that
i will be a jerk to a human
it happens
kind of a lot and
recently i saw a stray dog at this huge
intersection in los angeles and nobody
was stopping nobody was stopping so i
pull over and i can see that it's a
little tiny puppy
i know
and i could tell it was in really bad
shape okay so i get out of my car and
this guy yells at me he's like you dumb
bitch and i was like fuck you
so i'm like screaming at all these
people and i finally get like 12 lanes
to stop and i get closer to this puppy
and i get closer and closer to this
little tiny puppy and i see that this
little tiny puppy is a trash bag
[Applause]
but i had already been such an asshole
that there was really no turning back at
this point so i just had to
just had to lean in
[Applause]
and that's how i got tetanus